- I'm delighted to see you
all and I'm actually thrilled
that digital preservation would
bring so many people inside
on such a nice day, it's very promising.
I must say that I'm
quite honored to be here
in this lecture series, because
following the two previous,
Jim Reilly and Helen Shenton,
who have made such
significant contributions
to the profession.
I wanna just make clear
that I don't see myself
in that same role.
Rather as someone who sort
of walks the border between
people who use preserved information
and people who actually
preserve the information.
So I'm delighted to be
here in that capacity.
I will not speak about preservation today
from a professional perspective,
because I am after all
a historian, not a
preservationist, as Bobby said.
Nor will I speak necessarily
from a personal point of view
although I want to make clear
that all the views that
I express are actually
strictly my own and not
those of any organization
with which I have worked.
I also want to say that I'm going to speak
in a very strong voice.
I'm not going to be very
nuanced about what I say.
So I imagine that this will
spark a number of questions.
But I wanna just sweep
away some of the cobwebs
in terms of general
understandings of preservation
and of the specific role that
digital preservation plays
in our culture today.
Because that's what I want to talk about.
I want to talk about preservation
from a social perspective.
The role of preservation in culture
and particularly our
culture at this moment,
which I've characterized as
the age of abundance of information.
It's a period of information profligacy
and I think actual promiscuity.
But it also, it doesn't
mean that we have any more
attention span, in fact the challenge is
that we have more information
and the same finite amount of attention.
And I think this goes
very much to the thing
that I want to talk about most,
and that is the need to shape and select
the historical record in a
way that we have not done
in analog preservation.
Not that we haven't done
it, but we've done it
in a very different way.
So I want to focus on the social context
of digital preservation.
Preservation of born digital materials.
Most of all I want to
talk about the value,
the value of preservation for society
and so I will actually talk about
the economics of information.
I don't want you to be worried
I'm not an economist either
and I'm not going to talk economies,
but I have worked with
economists on this issue
and they have a lot to tell us about value
and how societies decide to
commit resources to one thing
and not to another.
What I say will apply in
part to analog materials
that have been converted to digital.
But I really want to address
the challenge of born digital
because it is the particular challenge
that has been given to
us in this generation,
whether we like it or not and
whether we trained for this.
This is actually our challenge now
and it's something that we
need to take very seriously
because the clock is ticking
on a whole variety of fronts
and it's not just the content
that we need to be preserving
it's the professional skills
that we need to develop
in order to deal with a
very changing environment
of information, and changing
value of information.
And by economics, I'm not
going to talk about cost models
or business models or anything
having to do with capitalism
or the free market.
I mean simply that the
allocation of resources,
which are always scarce, to
some things and not to another.
So how is it that we
decide to put money here
because it's always at the
expense of something else,
or so we think.
And so how do we actually
make those decisions?
It's about judgements and
it's about our sense of value,
because everything that
has value costs something,
people, time and yes money.
So where does preservation
fit into the list of things
that our society deems most
important, if not essential?
In other words, as I sometimes wonder,
does anybody out there really get it,
how important preservation is?
And the answer to that
question is, yes definitely,
they definitely do.
People definitely get the value
of preservation in society.
They have a special name
for it, they call it access.
I think the problem from
preservation's point of view
is that what they don't get is that
there's a relationship between
preservation and access.
That without preservation
there can be no access.
And I think that there's a way that we,
in the preservation community,
and people who care about
the historical record,
can, if not make them
care about preservation,
for the process itself can
make them care very much
about the outcomes of preservation,
and therefore support
preservation as it should be.
I mean this is, this
lack of identification
between access and preservation is acute
in the digital realm, partly
because digital content is so,
is not very long lived.
And I mean that in many sense,
there hasn't been information
or digital information
for long and it certainly
doesn't last that long.
But the failure I think goes
far deeper than the sort of,
you know, what me worry storage is cheap,
Alfred E Neuman school of preservation,
which I've heard an astounding
number of technologists say.
Technologists who really
should know better
because they've lost data.
So I just, I want to say
just a word about the idea
of cheap storage, and this
is a very serious point.
Storage requires energy and
we're not just talking about
digital storage, we're talking
about all forms of storage
as you know.
The use of power will never ever be cheap.
I remember the days, I
miss the days actually,
when experts would say that, you know,
energy is actually not
going to be a problem
because of nuclear power.
And in fact nuclear power will be so cheap
that we will stop metering it.
And I think that we're now living through
an absolutely horrifying
catastrophe that shows
just how expensive, not only energy is,
and nuclear power in particular,
but how incredibly dependent
we are on the power grid
in ways that we can hardly calculate.
I'm not saying that, you know,
we should go back to paper
but I am saying that we need to attend to
the entire spectrum of
issues that are related to
digital storage and
the digital life cycle.
It goes far beyond servers,
it goes beyond the power grid itself.
So the message about
preservation needs to be heard
at the very highest levels.
It needs to be seen as
critical infrastructure
which of course it is.
I think more to the point the,
it's cheap so we can store everything,
misses the single most
important point which is
not everything is equally valuable.
It avoids the very tough
question of selection
which I think is absolutely critical
and even more so in an age of abundance.
And I know this is very
controversial in some areas
and even in special
collections where people feel
that selection is a way
of limiting and biasing
the historical record, that it's difficult
and it is by definition, prejudicial.
And I say, yes it is,
but we have no choice.
In fact selection and collection building
has always been culturally inflected.
It has always reflected the
cultural biases of the people
who create information
and the people who are
successive stewards of that.
And I have to say as a
historian, you know I got that,
I understood that the
historical record was not
absolutely reflective of everything.
That's why I went to school
to learn how to use resources
and to have them tell
me what I wanted to hear
rather than just rely on
the things that were there.
And further more it makes
me believe that no matter
what we leave to some extent,
the skill of interpretation
lies with the interpretor.
But we need to give them the
best possible perspective.
The best possible choice.
I will say also that having
studied for a long time
in the USSR, I don't
believe that information
wants to be free.
I actually think that
the historical record
is extremely important to
be conscious stewards of
because information is very
easy to use and to manipulate
for whatever purposes
you want, good or ill.
And just one final point of introduction,
those are my priors,
before we start talking
about the good news
about digital preservation as
well as some of the cautions.
And that is what I know
is both as a historian
because of the people
that I have worked with.
I have spent many years working
in the Library of Congress
and working with the Library of Congress
and in many other places in
which I've just sponged up
as much information as I could.
And I think the thing that
I learned most importantly
was what I saw the audio
visual preservationist
grapple with at the Library of Congress.
That audio visual, you're
already dealing with
an historical record which
is extremely fragile.
Which is already discounted historically
as not significant although,
you know, we find out too late
that it is significant.
And so, also, how to deal
with things which are dynamic.
That is they are dynamic in time.
Because I think this is another challenge
in digital preservation, is
a mind set that preservation
is about fixing things once and for all.
Having the right standards,
fixing the right version.
This is simply not going to be the case
in digital preservation.
So I think for those who
are shy about getting into
digital preservation,
at least make friends
with friends in audio,
with people in audio visual preservation
because they have a lot
of this in their DNA.
How to actually look at
this kind of material
and assess its value.
So I want to start with the good news
about digital preservation
because there has been
an enormous amount of good news,
and it is mostly good news.
It's amazing to think how far we've gotten
in just 15 years roughly.
First, in terms of awareness,
the fact is that there are a
lot of people who are aware
of the need for digital preservation now.
You could say that everyone
who's experienced some loss
of data or having to upgrade
data understands that.
There's also a huge number
of technical advances
and I won't list them all
because there are so many
but in terms of preservation
improved bit storage
including the move to
the Cloud which I think
is going to give us some kind of scale
that we have longed for.
Also better understanding of file formats
and there has been enormous
amount of work done
in preservation meta data.
Really spectacular work
We're also seeing on the landscape
increased institutional
commitments to digital preservation
and I think that from our
perspective, in this library,
that's the most significant.
We've seen national libraries
taking responsibility
for some domain.
We see movie studios seriously investing
in digital preservation.
Financial companies have been
doing this for a long time.
And there are a lot of
data archives, you know,
it's not as if we had to
invent digital preservation
for ourselves in the library world.
Almost everything that
we want to know and use
has been done already and
forged for us in another sector.
Some institutions have even sprung up
just to deal with preserving
the cultural heritage.
I say some, but in fact
I have in mind one,
which is the internet archive.
The internet archive that started in 1996
with a typical sort of know no bounds,
I want everything approach.
And it's been simply doing and learning,
it's an iterative
approach, that its founder
Brewster Kahle knows from the tech world.
You got a problem, you try a solution.
That doesn't work, you try it again.
You never wait for version 3.0
because then it's too late.
And I think that's very
hard for some library staff,
library professionals to understand,
coming from at least a paper based world.
I think also the other
thing that's important is,
on the issue of scale,
we've seen several models
of shared stewardship be merged.
I think everybody who knows the least bit
about digital technology
knows that preserving data
can't be done in the old
fashioned library way of,
you know, one library one
campus in siloed collections.
In fact there has to be a
scaled effort to build at least
the infrastructure for
digital preservation.
This has been forged by the
National Science Foundation
when they put together the
Office of Cyber Infrastructure
in which they felt that all of their
extremely well funded preservation,
sorry science directorates,
still could not tackle
preservation on their own.
Or the building of the
infrastructure it had to be done
at scale which meant across institutions
and disciplinary lines.
I want to touch briefly on some bad news
which is, which is
essentially all of the above.
Everything that I said
has some down side to it,
not surprisingly.
So in the area of technical advances
we've made enormous strides
in preservation advances.
But we have not kept pace
with the technical advances
in the creation of information.
In fact we're falling very far behind.
There's not much we can do about that
but that is the case that
the ability to create data
will always outstrip our
ability to preserve it.
We have already technically far acceded
the amount of information there is,
has far acceded the storage
capacity world wide.
And this is just of scientific data.
So even those people who were power users
are beginning to understand
that they can't save everything.
I want to say about awareness,
I think there is a great deal of awareness
in the cultural heritage
institutions about
the need for digital preservation.
But we see a lot of institutions saying,
but that doesn't mean me.
That doesn't mean me because
I don't have the capacity.
I don't have the funding,
I don't have the expertise.
And I think the saddest cases in my mind
are historical societies
and small regional libraries
and in the major
metropolitan public libraries
which have a very valuable role
in collecting regional history
not just serving the public best sellers.
And I think that they're really bereft,
they're really left on
their own in this world
and so that's why I think the
idea of shared stewardship
is even more important to
build a robust infrastructure
that small institutions can use almost as
a kind of service bureau.
And I think the preservation
world has really modeled
this extremely well in the field services
that they provide in some of the,
some of the service bureaus
that they have for preservation
that serve very small constituents.
After all we know that
local history in the micro
is very important.
Now I wanna speak slightly
against the grain here
and talk about the bad news in terms of
institutional commitments
because I talked about
national libraries, financial
companies, movie studios.
I want to know where the
ARL libraries are in this
and I'm not talking
about converted materials
when they've done a
spectacular job of converting
their materials for access purposes.
Nor am I talking about the
extensive work that has been done
in negotiating access
to scholarly literature
which is born digital,
access which has a preservation
back end in many cases.
There's a kind of, if
you go out of business,
we get to keep this.
I'm talking about the
born digital material
that the humanist of the
future will be using.
Not scholarly literature
but the primary sources
of our culture.
I think to a surprising degree
I think research libraries
whose specialty actually
is that have been really
missing in action and I think that
there's a significant
risk that this will go on
for some time if libraries
don't just step in
and try to do it, and
do just a little bit.
You don't have to do much.
But work with your
special collections area.
You know what your
collecting strengths are
just go out and do some web archiving.
Or something else, partner with people
who are digital creators because
there's a lot of opportunity
there for your feet to get wet
in a kind of no fault area.
I think that from an
economic point of view
there might be very compelling reasons why
research libraries are among
the last to enter into the space.
Not among the last but
certainly likert I'd say
considering the importance
of these institutions.
And it is, as I learned from economists
on the Blue Ribbon Task Force,
it's an economic reason.
It's because, to some extent,
libraries have lost their
incentive to preserve.
And I know that sounds counter-intuitive
because why would a
library need an incentive
if in fact it's their mission to preserve.
But I think that sometimes
missions are lip service
and that you can have a mission
that you're not able to fulfill.
And it still means a great deal to you
but it's not something which is actionable
that you will actually
dedicate a lot of money to.
And I think preservation
is at risk of becoming this
in the digital world.
I think the incentive
for libraries to preserve
analog collections has been access.
You could not serve
readers without providing
a book for them.
And you could not serve this faculty
without having books that
dated from 1850 or before.
It was simply something
that you had to do.
Libraries weren't founded
around preservation
they were founded around
access and preservation
was built as a back end to support access
that people wanted.
You know the country has been
very slow at a policy level
to move in step with the digital realm.
The copyright law,
despite recommendation for
tiny incremental changes to section 108,
to allow copying of digital
materials for libraries.
That law has not been amended,
our Congress seems to be
quite distracted by a
number of other things.
I'd say in the meantime, the
good news is, in the meantime
copyright law has become quite irrelevant
to a large number of people
who are creating data.
And I think that gives
us a real opportunity.
I don't think that as long
as materials are licensed,
we deal with the licensing regime
as opposed to the copyright law,
we're going to be doing
significantly differently
than we are now, and I think
we've made considerable strides
in that area.
But there's a lot of,
even in the area of scholarly literature,
there's an increasing
amount of scholarship
which is written outside of journals
which is very important.
There are lots of scholarly
blogs in certain fields
where actually, which are
quite preservation worthy
and are looking for
homes for preservation.
I wanna talk also about the good news
of shared stewardship
models because in fact,
I mean I talked about the
shared stewardship model
as a good thing, and it is.
Actually there have been
a large number that say,
ENDIP is one, Program
and Locks is another,
and HathiTrust is yet a third.
But particularly when it
comes to universities,
there's a downside to that
which is sharing is not easy
and universities are,
particularly the ones
that have the richest collections,
there in a very competitive
stance, one with another.
They compete for students,
they compete for faculty,
they compete for collections,
they compete at sports.
And I think that this
is very much out of step
with what's needed in the digital world.
I do believe that in fact
there are universities
talking about building shared
preservation infrastructure
because they've encountered
already that this is not
something that they can
do except collectively.
I would say Locks is an example of that,
HathiTrust is an example of that.
But I think it's a very serious issue
which needs to be addressed
in the next couple of years
and I expect Yale will be
part of the solution for that.
And be eager to join, I mean,
even Harvard has announced
that it's willing to join
in some aspects of sharing
collections and preservation.
So I would say there's
a fairly good example
up in the brick campus up north.
I want to spend the rest of my time here
talking specifically
about some of the findings
from the Blue Ribbon Task Force
on sustainable digital
preservation and access.
It's in part because I think
this is work that tends to be,
that hasn't gotten a
lot of traction because
it looks like it's about
economics and I think
that that scares a lot of people away.
But I think it's actually a salubrious way
of looking at the challenges
of building support
for preservation because in the end,
preservation has to pay its way.
It doesn't have to pay its way financially
but it has to be something
that society says
it is willing to invest in
as opposed to something else
and I think we can make a
very good case for that.
Several years ago the
National Science Foundation
and the Library Congress
got together to put,
it wanted to get
preservationists and economists,
you know, academic
economists, real economists,
to talk about the fundamental economics
of digital sustainability.
Why, because digital
preservation had been dealt with
as a technical problem,
and as legal problem,
and as a collecting
problem, but never seriously
as an economic problem.
And I'll say economists do
not think of what they do
as business, business
models and cost models,
that's actually what people
in business school do
as they told me on the task force.
They actually look at society's engagement
with the commitment of resources
to things that they care about.
We looked at it from a
very, a global perspective.
We had, we worked for two
years, we produced two reports.
The first report was purely descriptive.
It just looked at the world
and said what have we done,
what solutions are there
for digital preservation
and paying for it, and what
lessons have been learned.
What are the things that people have tried
that have not succeeded
that we should not try.
The second year was
what we call normative,
looking at where we're going,
or actually in this case,
looking at where we wanted to
go, and then plotting a course
for how we got, how we
would get there from here.
It did sometimes feel like, that you know,
we were maining.
The person would just say
well we can't get there
from here you know.
But in fact there is a way
to engage all the sectors
that we need in economic
support of this activity.
In some ways simply by
re-calibrating how we describe
what we do, and addressing
a different audience
than we have.
The economist did a very
good job of characterizing
preservation as an economic activity
and I won't give your their economies.
It's incredibly funny
and amusing to hear them
describe preservation in economic terms.
They have an array of technical terms
which are really quite
interesting and get at
some very core concepts but,
as the writer of the report,
I found that they needed
translation constantly
and so I will speak to you
in translated economies,
and tell you that for digital preservation
we determined that there were
five conditions for sustainability
and there are only five conditions.
This is all incidentally in the report
and I will tell you how to find the report
at the end of the talk.
I'm not going to give you a URL,
I will give you the title
again so you can google it.
The URL is a little ungainly.
So the five conditions for support are,
a recognition of the
benefits of preservation
by decision makers.
And a decision maker is
anybody who is in a position
to commit a resource to something,
or to influence a decision I should say.
Who is a decision maker at Yale?
Well obviously the President
is, the head of the library is.
Anybody who runs a budget is.
But the faculty are also decision makers.
They can set priorities for
what's important on campus.
So but the important thing is to recognize
the benefits of preservation.
That is, what is it that stakeholders get
out of preservation?
Again it's about the outcomes.
The second thing that's
needed is a process
for selecting digital
materials with long term value.
That's very very difficult
and I think people found it
the most difficult task.
But there was absolutely
no interest in anybody
from the task force
coming out and saying that
we should be keeping
everything because we can.
It was very clear to
the people who put this,
who charged the task force,
that in fact presidents of
universities for example
would not invest in digital preservation
if they thought it was a black hole
and it would be collecting
everything indiscriminately.
They wanted a lot of work
going into a selection
which I think is very smart.
There have to be incentives,
the third is there have to be
incentives for decision makers
to make the decision to
preserve in the public interest.
And I will talk a little
bit about incentives
because it seems like a sort
of odd thing to talk about
in preservation and odd
in terms of mission work
but in fact incentives are key to actually
getting things done.
There needs to be, the fourth is,
there needs to be appropriate
organization and governance
of digital preservation activities.
And I'll say that I'd be
surprised if this campus
were any different than any
campus I've ever been on
where digital preservation
happens in multiple places
and nobody knows where they are.
Nobody knows what other people are doing
and they don't even know about
the duplication of effort
that they're making.
So it is really critical
that there be a strategy
for digital preservation
and that people know what the strategy is
and there be clear lines of responsibility
for who does what.
We heard from many government agencies
that produce public records
that, you know, are by law
to be preserved.
Somebody was ready to hand
off a record, a digital record
for example, be he a
scientist in a laboratory
or somebody in immigration.
They would turn to somebody
and say so where do I send this
and there was no answer,
nobody knew who was in charge.
And so I think that it's
quite essential that people
be tasked specifically and that, second,
that everybody knows who
is tasked specifically
about who is in charge of what.
It's the only way to actually
implement the strategy
because it is after all quite,
we're dealing with a femoral
and distributed materials.
It's not as if somebody can just put
a whole bunch of books in a room and say,
okay, let's take care of this.
It has to be handled in a distributed way.
The fifth challenge is the
mechanisms for securing
ongoing and efficient
allocation of resources
to digital preservation activities.
Efficient doesn't mean cheap it means
that you get the biggest
bang for your bucks.
So there's an appropriate
amount of redundancy
but there's not unnecessary duplication.
Not surprisingly the
things that people found
the greatest challenge about
meeting those conditions.
I shouldn't say, incidentally,
that the first year
we spent looking for
somebody who could claim
that they have fulfilled
all five of those conditions
and the closest we got
was somebody who thought
they were doing, oh, sort
of three, maybe four.
But then on closer examination
we asked them questions
and decided no they weren't
actually doing that many either.
So it's complicated and it's not as if
there's a model out there
that people can hand off
to somebody else.
Getting into conversation,
I think, with people,
other people who are doing
digital preservation,
is possibly the first intelligent step.
But almost in order of the challenges,
I'll tell you what they were.
The first was uncertainty
about selection criteria
which I mentioned, for
assessing long term value.
On the one hand we had
scientists talking about
large scale data sets.
Some of them could say
well we know that those,
you know, those petabytes
of data from space,
will not be useful after
10 years because, you know,
we'll have superseded
the observational data
with something else.
On the other hand there was a
different set of astronomers
who said you know what,
all astronomical data
is historical data.
We can't get rid of anything.
So they were having a hard
time sorting through that one
but they did realize they
had to make a choice.
So they were thinking about
ways to sample historical data
so that they could do it cheaply.
We also found a great challenge
with the small handcrafted
digital collections,
many of which are bound on
campuses made by students
and faculty members.
And then the biggest one which
we decided we couldn't avoid
is the plethora of new
genres that are emerging
on the web, mediated by social media
and the so-called open web.
Things like Wikipedia and Twitter.
Things that we know are of
enormous social significance
but what part of it is significant?
How we collect it, how we save it,
what are the copyright and
ownership claims to it?
Not a clue, absolutely not a clue.
I think it was on the
basis of the complete gulf
about how important it was versus
knowing what to do about it,
that really prompted the
Library of Congress to say
you know, we're going to
take the Twitter archive.
We don't know what that means,
we have no idea what that means
but Twitter doesn't either
and who better to find
out with than Twitter.
So that's the kind of partnership
where you can go into it
with an expectation of
failure but it's a failure,
but failures are learning experiences.
If it's failure without
a learning experience
then it is really a failure.
But if you go into something knowing that
the outcome actually is knowledge,
not necessarily saving something,
then you can get pretty
far with trying out
different methods for selection.
I can tell you my
colleagues at the library
were absolutely gobsmacked
when the first public reaction
we heard some people
saying, hey that's great,
were people individually trying to reach
individuals in the Library
of Congress saying,
that Twitter, I want my
Twitter back, you know.
I didn't know that it was
going to be preserved for ever.
I never knew that it was,
that anyone had a right
to preserve it.
And of course it's all
very clear on the Twitter
when you click through the licence that,
unless you make an exemption,
you know, it is actually,
it's not your private property any more.
And people publish on line
and it's totally accessible
but they're very sensitive
about it being preserved.
So you run into some
very unexpected issues
simply by trying things out.
There's also another
challenge which I'll get into.
It's quite specific in every community.
The scholarly community
or scientific community
or Hollywood for example.
But there's a really
fundamental misalignment
of incentives to preserve.
Copyright law is completely
out of whack with
what we need to be doing in
terms of copyrighted material
and the rewards in the academy for
attending to digital preservation
where it matters the most
are also out of whack.
And I will actually spend some
time on talking about that.
And then finally I want
to say that another thing
that was really baffling
which I don't think
we're ever going to solve is
trying to discriminate between
preservation, the cost of
making something accessible,
versus the cost of making
something, preserving something.
In fact they're not separable,
and so teasing out preservation
costs as opposed to
access costs is a fool's game.
I think it's much better to
thing of long term sustained
data management in which
you look at every object
as having a lifecycle.
And the lifecycle can be five
years, it can be one year
and it can be 50 years
but it's much more useful
to think about lifecycle
costs and lifecycle management
of digital data.
And it also makes it a whole lot easier
to think about selection in this case.
The really good news is we
did find that once the risks
were identified and we
recommended that everybody
doing an assessment of
where they are with this,
do a self assessment of where they are
based on some of the things in our report.
We found that in fact
for nearly everything
that we thought of as a
risk, there is a mitigation.
There is actually a lot to be done
in order to make the environment friendly
for digital preservation.
And the really good news I think is that
it is everybody's problem.
It's not Yale's problem
and it's not my problem.
It's actually everybody's problem.
So when rumor first spread
that the Library of Congress
and NSF were looking to put
together this task force
on economics we had a flood
of people volunteering
time and effort and money, and
a lot of interest on the part
of people in a university administration.
Of course they also thought
that we would hand them
a blueprint for what is to be done.
Actually a business model as
opposed to an economic model.
But I think economic models are,
business models are
actually pointless without
an economic model in.
We did get fairly far to
articulating several types
of economic models, some for profit
and for the four profit sector,
and some not for profit.
So the three things that I want to say
as the final recommendations which I think
are most important for this community are,
and they are just three.
They're not easy.
Is first and foremost to
articulate a compelling
value proposition for preservation.
I said first that in the
beginning that people
really do care about preservation.
They just don't call it
preservation, they call it access.
I think that particularly
in the preservation field,
if you really want to get more resources,
and the right kind of resources for work,
start talking about the
outcomes of preservation.
Start talking about the
things that you can do
with preserved assets, or
however you want to call them.
In the scientific world they
can talk about the promise
of future productivity of science.
How do we talk about that in a library?
How do we actually talk
about the future productivity
of our students and our faculty?
Well we talk about it
actually all the time
though without the collections,
research and teaching
is really engendered.
So talk first about what
the outcomes of preservation
are going to be, and then talk about
what it takes to get there from here.
The value of proposition
of saving astronomical data
is going to be different
from saving feature films
for example, but every audience has
it's own sort of sweet spot in terms of
what it really wants to pay attention to.
But I think I would start first with,
what is the benefit of preservation?
That's the recognition of benefit
on the part of stakeholders.
The second thing is to provide
clear incentives to preserve
in the public interest.
What does that mean to provide incentives
and clear incentives to
preserve in the public interest?
Well providing incentives
for stakeholders,
as we say anybody who
cares about the outcome
of preservation, to preserve
digital assets to directly,
or to provide preservation
services for others
and tailoring those incentives
to the prevailing community
norms and to information
policy regulations
and privacy concerns, is really
what we're talking about.
We're talking about both
creating incentives,
positive things that
get people to preserve
and also removing disincentives,
of which there are many.
To take a fairly simple example,
I'll take a bench scientist
at Yale University
or a medical scientist at Yale.
One incentive that a scientist
has to preserve digital data
is the possibility of reusing the data
if in fact they're interested
in sharing the data.
A much stronger incentive
would be if his grant
depended upon digital curation.
If the grant actually
stipulated that the data
had to be managed and archived
and that digital curation
was part of the grant,
and there was money in the grant for it.
And there would be a penalty to be paid
if the curation didn't happen.
Now that's really an incentive.
It's one thing for NSF to say,
everybody needs to save their data
and curate their data,
but that's not enough
because I can't think of,
we actually asked people at
the Foundation and they said,
well privately they didn't
know of any particular grant
which had been denied a PI
because they hadn't saved data
from a previous grant.
They gave them a hard time maybe
but they didn't actually
deny research funds.
Research funds is what
researchers care about
so holding back money
would be very important.
A big advance is that NSF is now saying
the people have to have
a data management plan.
That's very good, nobody knows what
a data management plan is yet.
But I see this as an opportunity
for libraries frankly.
I mean how many of you have gone over
to science laboratories and say,
hey you got a data management
plan that you're worried about
maybe I can help you.
This is really an opportunity to begin
data curation where it
counts which is at the bench.
I'd also say that there
are positive disincentives
for scientists to curate data.
And what are they?
Well because every second,
every penny that's not spent
on research is really a
demerit in his portfolio
because there is no reward
in his reward system
or her reward system for
curating and preserving data.
It's just time away from
something that is rewarded.
So I think the incentives
are really out of skew
within the university itself.
That on the one hand you
reward people for creating data
on the other hand there's
a positive disincentive
for people preserving data
and somehow they think that
all of, somehow things are
going to end up in the library
sort of magically packaged and
ready for you to take care of
and serve up again.
This is a fundamental misunderstanding.
Data curation really
begins with the creator
and it should be in
partnership with librarians,
preservationists, data scientists,
informatics specialists,
whatever you want to call them.
Every discipline will
have a different name.
But it's a partnership that
begins at the very beginning.
I think that libraries
have, well I should say,
universities have a second opportunity
as well as a responsibility
and that is, you have,
thousands of students coming
through here every year.
You teach them literacy in many ways.
Media literacy, reading
literacy, mathematical literacy.
Digital literacy is what is needed now
because our students are digital,
they've grown up digital.
They know how to use machines fluently,
many times better than
we do we think, we fear.
But that doesn't mean that
they're literate necessarily,
and they know how to use information well.
There's a chance that,
as well as an obligation,
that we can take the current
generation of sort of
web 2.0ers, sort of read
write culture of technology,
and turn it into a read, write,
curate and preserve culture.
I think that everybody who goes through
an undergraduate program
at any good university
or college, where actually it
should start in high school.
People should be taught how
to manage their own data
while they're creating it.
Not just how to create a paper
or a project that gets an A,
and it be judged only on
the intellectual merit,
but just as much as you would
give a demerit for plagiarism,
for example, or worse than a demerit,
not taking care of data properly,
file naming formats and things like that,
is something that people
need to learn essentially
from the cradle, because
it's not something
that they're going to
intuit until it's too late.
So finally let me just end
with a few exhortations
to people particularly in the library,
and particularly in preservation.
I think that first I
want to emphasize again
how crucial selection is.
I think that archivists
have a unique perspective
on dealing with abundance
and sorting through
what's important to document,
what's important to save,
what's important to sample.
And I think audio visual archivists
are particularly adept at this.
I think we have a lot to learn from them.
I also think that preservation is,
and I know this will sound somewhat bold
and even counter-intuitive
in these budgetary times,
but I really do believe
passionately that preservation
is emerging as a keystone
of the university
and its social worth.
I really think in this
time when universities
feel besieged by so much, and
their whole social mission
is under question from many
sectors, they can claim,
rightly so, that they
contribute to knowledge,
that they really contribute
to the knowledge economy.
But so do a lot of other sectors.
A lot of private sectors
contribute to knowledge as well.
The one thing that the
private sector will never do.
And this was demonstrated
roundly by our economists is,
they will never care about preservation.
They will never ensure the
continuity of information
from one generation to another.
It is impossible for market forces
to actual take care of that.
And so I think that, of all
the things that libraries do,
on university campuses,
I have heard people on
universities administration
speculating how all of them could go away.
Many of the things we
love most about libraries
can very well be imagined
as being superseded
by commercial services frankly.
Search, for example, access for example.
But no one believes that
anybody but a university
is going to preserve.
And so I think it means that
this is really the golden
age of preservation.
That if the university
can really configure
a lot of its information
culture around the creation
and curation of data,
that the library really
stands to benefit enormously.
It means a lot of changes in
the profession of preservation.
It means working with a
lot of different skills
and developing different
skillsets than we had before
but I really believe that it
is, it really is the beginning
of a marvelous age for preservation.
Preservation, the paradigm preservation
for the digital world is not about fixity,
it's about incremental responsibilities.
You can think long term
but really incrementally.
The key is to think about
hand-offs, secure hand-offs.
Making sure that data is
well curated and making sure
that it is handed off to
somebody who can curate it
and steward it in the next step.
I think you have a lot of skills on campus
that are very good at this.
I think there are many
people at the Beinecke
who know precisely how to
identify really important
content creators, and
collectors of content.
How to develop relationships with them
and how to ensure that their
collection of information
comes to the Beinecke when
they are ready to move it
to a stewardship organization.
Take that paradigm, move it
online, go to digital creators,
and I think you have exactly
the same thing going on.
What is it that makes this
obligation for preservation
so important?
I think it's important for
us, not just as individuals,
and as families, and as
researchers at universities,
but I think it is really
vital for us as a species,
as homo sapiens, and I
mean that quite literally.
We differ from our fellow
species in many ways.
But scientists are telling us every day
we differ a lot less from our
fellow species than we think.
But there is one thing
incontestably we differ from
all other species with,
and that is the ability
to create artificial memory.
To actually embody
knowledge in external forms
that we then can pass on
across time, across space,
and across multiple generations.
We are the only species that does that,
and we do it through preservation
so, I thank you very much.
(applause)
As you can tell I think
this is the beginning
of a very exciting time for preservation
and I know that I have
given a lot of information.
Not nearly as much as I
would've liked to of course
but I would to commend
to you the two reports
of the task force and I
would simply, I would say
just google sustainable
economics digital planet.
That's a lot easier than
trying to find the URL.
The reports are actually on
the San Diego Supercomputer site.
I also want to recommend to
you the Library of Congress
has just published its 10 year
review of the ENDIP program
and it's now online,
www.digitalpreservation.gov.
And there's a full discussion about
the many different models
of shared stewardship there
that I commend to you.
They're very frank discussions
of the various efforts
that were tried some failed,
but in the end succeeded.